Comcast look I know it takes a village
to get a movie made and that's expensive
but this is entirely too many logos east
and west do not mistrust each other
because we are armed we are armed
because we mistrust each other
Regan narration air Regan reading we
need to show we're in the eighties sir
we just opened with the mr. Gorbachev
speech from Reagan wearing a boy Eddie's
new order it is Sir and if you were
gonna shoot him why ran him twice I get
maybe ramming him once he was running
perpendicular to your car but ran him
again after that isn't that just a waste
of time when you plan on shooting him to
death in the end anyway a fat guy shot
another guy I don't know in one half of
Berlin during the Cold War so he could
steal his watch or some and I'm just
like this is a pretty good movie by the
end why does it have such a sketchy and
terrible opening who thought these first
three minutes were super compelling why
can't Charlize be in the opening scene
Charlize has now appeared in movies
where she takes a nice bath a milk bath
a couple of couples baths and at least
one regular bath what's next to Chipotle
baths a garlic bath a mud bath mr. pro
bath agenda has got to stop Charlie's
final rain is a big shot spy and
probably don't give a fuck but that
window is wide fucking open half of
London as a clear view of her Big Ben's
goddamn it is so washed out and filtered
it might as well be black and white
maybe that's the point but if it is the
point sure who doesn't keep their
expositional nostalgic pictures in a
random bathroom drawer I don't know I
just don't think this movie is 1989
enough can we maybe find a way to
squeeze in something about Pete Rose or
maybe Tim Burton's Batman Taylor Swift
Burt Louie news makeup to cover her
other facial injuries but I guess ran
out before she could get to the eyes
then well earlier ten days later text
I'm just now piecing together that this
movie is going to do the whole flashback
the entire movie a bit at a time while
the main character is being interrogated
or interviewed in the present thing from
well Titanic Slumdog Millionaire the
usual suspects young guns to Vanilla Sky
Mission Impossible three Hey - Tom
Cruise movies young guns - that Natalie
Portman SNL rap video Citizen Kane hey I
like this movie and it's already told me
this is based on a graphic novel but
this unnecessary spray paint graphic
labels make it look way too Suicide
Squad for me also only nine minutes into
the film it finally begins and honestly
the first nine minutes we're so bland
you better have one mother of a surprise
payoff in
or you know Russian is excellent and
expert in the escape-and-evasion
provision tin intelligence collection
atomic bond also what an expositional
resume we promised a spyglass immunity
in exchange for a document on microfilm
codenamed the list
wait the list is the codename for a list
that contains names of spies I even have
a codename tonight it's literally what
it is also movie rips off the list of
all the spies names MacGuffin from all
the spy movies David person he's on
number one in Berlin
he's your point of contact and 100%
certain to either be evil or have
ulterior motives if I've ever movie
before in my life and I have to strike
from the tip the Virgin Mary of all the
whiskey's in all the world this
character in this movie decided to crown
as champion Jack Daniels a fine enough
whiskey from my home state of Tennessee
that is in no way the best of the best
in which some would even argue is just
well marketed swill it's a russian world
bucket sideways but that's such an
ignorant thing to do if the Russians
love their children too this is highly
sensitive trust no one
Lorraine is a goddamn super spy dude do
you really have to spout this lazy crap
before she goes on a mission you
remember mr. Bremen bitches don't you of
course you do so you knew she was coming
planned to kill her but still announce
yourself like this and give her time to
reach down to her shoes despite this
potentially fatal conflict in the back
seat this motherfucker continues to
drive rather than stopping the car
getting out and shooting Lorraine
luckily this chase ended in the part of
West Berlin where you can easily dispose
of comatose henchmen in broad daylight
without anyone noticing you know what
probably doesn't blend in that expensive
ass sports car that's being haphazardly
driven in the middle of the day
[Music]
geumhui seasick REM effete waited until
now to ask this very important question
to one of his henchmen what the hell was
all the beating for then two versions of
Blue Monday were used for this movie and
neither one was by orgy so someone's
following her and she smokes got it
smokey sure wastes a lot of time doesn't
it I will not release this body without
to collect information it's a simple
mistake who's not in German if you don't
make simple mistakes wait what Lorraine
goes to complete the first item on her
to-do list gets denied by a mortician
and just pieces out to take a nice bath
the hell kind of spy is she also why
does she use ice pad stand I'm the pain
when plenty of legal and illegal but
easily obtainable drugs would do the job
faster and with much less lugging of ice
buckets in Tirana
I can only assume that this expositional
dream sequence was inserted to spark
debate over whether or not Lorraine is a
replicant radio was embedded in your
headboard yet another idat8 he's got
wrong about the future and this movie
loves its mere shots maybe too much like
Charlie's went sole method during Snow
White and the Huntsman she started
demanding tons of mirrors in a contract
I want satchel dead or alive he's a
black eye to the crown whoa that's
racist oh he said black hi carry on why
are these dick holes approaching so
cautiously just to give Lorraine enough
time to get set up for ask a curry dude
you don't need to keep using the silent
motion tricks under the circumstances of
your partner being choked out by a
garden hose you can just tell your guys
what to do or even ask the rain what her
deal is has anyone tried that
since this is Germany I'll assume this
is technically a Vilhelm screen this
movie confirms that yes women can also
be Jason Bourne
ah yes leaving a dog-eared copy of
Machiavelli's The Prince in the
foreground of Percival's house is an
extremely subtle way of letting us know
he's a selfish butthole no librarian is
Larry Flint champion of free speech this
is apparently the British spy version of
I only read it for the articles Jesus
Christ this version of der Kommissar was
released in 1982 and has nothing to do
with this era other than we're in
Germany also a hate der Kommissar this
movie has more liquor product placement
than a fucking DJ Khaled music video had
a hard-on for Jack Daniels considering
this movie is taking place in Cold War
Berlin in 1989 lucky us the fact that
this guy thinks he's being inconspicuous
sure it's good context for us but why
would Lorraine have all her different
passports laid out like this like what
if the housekeeper brings up extra
towels you don't think they're gonna see
that you should have applied for a
visitor's permit what kind of work do
you do
legal affairs luckily for Lorraine she
found the one customs agent in East
Berlin that speaks perfect English hell
it's hard to find a customs agent that
speaks perfect English in the u.s.
you're only being stalked seeks refuge
in movie theater playing stalker movie
what was this assholes plan he had
beaten Lorraine to the point she would
be easily transportable but because he
kicked her through the pink screen and
took forever to walk through it he
fucking lost her was this assholes plan
despite all this commotion outside the
building Lorraine still finds a side
exit no one knows about or is covering
there are enough of these shots of long
luscious drags off of cigarettes in this
movie that it's pretty much become
smoked pork he's pondering how to tell
Charlize about the magic loom they get
their orders from I look for pleasure in
the details I'm sure what went wrong
here but this progressive lesbian Side
Story kills the movies momentum and I
can't help but wonder if it's Sophia
boot Ella's inability to sell this line
even a little bit well even though
nothing was really discussed except for
the fact that Delvians French
intelligence and she offered a somewhat
cryptic warning to me that's enough shop
Talk let's make the hell out she give
you
she gave me nothing I know you wanted to
give us a flashback of her clearly
giving Charlize information they had to
ask her this four times before she said
anything
what interrogator debriefers going to
believe your answer after thinking about
it for that long goodbye did you think
Christ howís baktun stayed alive this
long if he announces his presence then
walks up behind a fucking spy with no
clue of what he has in front of it The
Mummy on her tummy it's a nice shot but
up there all alone isn't this a pretty
conspicuous way to have a clandestine
spy talk sure maybe no one can hear you
but you're drawing all kinds of
attention to yourselves given that
there's nothing to do up on top of that
tiny platform to nowhere except have
clandestine conversations lamp lamp lamp
lamp lamp first of all is 97 kilograms
with translates to 213 pounds the only
way James McAvoy could weigh that much
as if all of his split personalities
were real and were included in this
measurement oh yeah thanks for
remembering James in almost 20 minutes
since the movie Jack Daniels approach is
the list I can't make mistakes I mean is
being a spy mostly just drinking in bars
drinking at home smoking cigarettes
being beautiful women and talking about
the mission because if so I could do at
least four of those five things instead
Percival kept it a secret putting us in
a precarious position a lot of
alliteration from anxious atomic
assassins attempting to assuage angry
Authority through auditory aspersion oh
yeah so that's still a thing I swear to
God Charlie's just took this role to
wear pretty clothes learn jujitsu
chain-smoked and cuddle Sylvia boot Ella
you tell the truth you look different
cute romantic moment but does she tell
the truth even one time prior to the
very last scene though here is a man
about to watch these two pick a lock on
a restricted subway door and then just
drive off on his merry way without ever
reporting it or yelling hey stop that
and while that may be what a real
underpaid subway worker would actually
do it's still a sin Oh off with it
already what tough goes up with a
skateboard the illegal passport
operation also makes or paints
skateboards or are you telling me that
one of the illegal passport operations
employees take skateboards to work every
day in East Berlin his family who knows
spine class is a spot so why the would
they just waltz into a meeting of spies
doing spiced about like a special knock
hey it's us shop I was admittedly a kid
when the Berlin Wall fell but was it
really known days in advance what day
and time it was gonna come down this
movie makes it sound like it was I don't
remember that being the case I thought
it was more spontaneous than that a bit
again my textbooks taught me the
Christopher Columbus
was awesome at everything and never did
a bad thing so my education is up for
debate when you have Prince alien then
being shoot them Jesus what is this
asshole waiting for the 1961 Lincoln
Continental convertible she bounces
there right in the middle of a goddamn
firefight with multiple bad guys on
their ass and Lorraine leaves this
mother here by himself in the middle of
a fucking Lobby I don't care if this is
an unreliable narrative that's whack
[Applause]
furiosa origins I have to hand it to
this movie for this seemingly uncut shot
of a brutal and claustrophobic fight and
even if it's a little boredom it doesn't
have that shaky-cam aesthetic so it's
pretty cool original and awesome and
long and awesome three cents off god
damn it just when I give this movie
props for this fight scene they got a
tough King villain pulls a knife midway
through the fight cliche luckily for
Lorraine and spyglass these KGB
dickheads not only have stormtrooper aim
they immediately abandon the successful
strategy of shooting through the wall I
thought these KGB boys had radios and
which was how they were communicating
during the protest but no one calls to
let their comrades know that this ass
beating is taking place
you guys can punch and kick all you want
but if you stay in this room to do it
odds are you're both going to die from
the explosion or fire caused by any of
the eight things touching this radiator
back here under the window wait so the
dude that got his eyes gouged out and
its throat ripped open somehow runs
these mother whores down for one last
hurrah I haven't seen a villain
resurrection this contrived since the
very end of die hard Lorraine backs up
easily down the street even though the
asshole that shot at them wrecked and
totally blocked it I guess the bad guys
in this movie are basically video game
characters that disappear a few seconds
after they were vanquished at this point
I'm gonna have to create a new sudden
side view of a car definitely means
there's about to be a terrible wreck
leisure Lorraine and therefore movie has
time for this god damnit doesn't anyone
know how to approach a fucking spy in
this movie hmm pretty sure I've gotten
spine glass and satchel confused given
that they are both unknown s named spy
people in this does the movie know how
unnecessarily complicated this all is
Christ no one in Germany believed
you mean Lorraine who was extremely
freaked out injured and desperately
searching for a bug in a room stopped to
turn on the TV to listen to the news
she's smoking a blunt and bawling her
eyes out she's so sad about weed and
after all the scuffling the
back-and-forth the knife in the back and
all the bull he still ends up
successfully strangling her good for him
wait calm the hell on I know it's
emotional that Delphine was killed but
Lorraine neither attempt CPR nor tries
to immediately chase after the person
she knows did it say any one question
after you asked one well my best guess
is Marlborough also fourth-wall breaking
in the final act of a movie that already
has an unreliable narrator gonzo
aesthetics and too many flashes forward
and backwards to count I think we've
already broken all the narrative rules
thank you very much oh no don't touch
that sweet sweet Tennessee whiskey that
obviously funded this movie for
conscience after all you've done yeah
that's a good point actually
nice people that guys didn't hear the
difference I'm sure I've seen a more
dramatic death scene like probably Talia
al Ghul from The Dark Knight Rises but
this one is up there
David basketball have you been listening
dude not only yes she did and yes she
has but also she kind of had a good
reason there's the list alright I know
no oh
Borges this works
Luby waits until it moves to Paris
before playing the most London s song
ever god dammit doesn't anyone know how
to approach a fucking spy in this movie
I haven't seen this many feathers in the
air during a shootout since true romance
before you die I want to get this
through your thick primitive skull
because I'm multum Utley kind of the
villain in this movie and I'm the only
one that hasn't properly revealed the
totality of my plan yet damn it yeah
triple agent you never saw that coming
unless you've seen a few movies before
this way in which case this final whammy
ends up falling flat and feeling a bit
too hungry let's go home so not only is
mi6 barely worried about this extremely
dangerous and stupidly named the list
anymore
they're letting one of their most prized
assets lead the country
Jared you like this shit back here
excuse me my associates and I we uh we
made a little bet on what you do for a
living
and I won Tommy
of the beeping
this is the end shall we begin
it's never been like this in Berlin you
should have become a poet they should
have said oh this is highly sensitive
trust no one